Customs and Border Protection's says
it's taking immediate steps to implement
the executive order we don't know if or
when the more than 2300 children already
separated from their parents will be
reunited hundreds of people gathered at
New York's LaGuardia Airport last night
to welcome children headed to one of
more than 100 shelters in 17 states new
video provided by the government offers
a look inside a Florida shelter that
holds about 1,200 kids including many
separated from their families they're
now being treated by the government as
so-called unaccompanied children just
like minors who cross a border without
their parents
David Begg knows at a shelter near the
Mexican border in McAllen Texas David
good morning as we keep hearing a lot of
confusion this morning good morning Gail
that's the New Hope facility behind me
an official with Catholic Charities who
you actually spoke with gave us a
heads-up and said listen here at this
facility they have about 60 children
anywhere between 10 and 17 years old and
some of them have been separated from
their parents the question is what
happens next you're gonna hear from a
government official who actually used to
run the government's program that takes
care of children separated from their
parents he did it under President Obama
and he said even then and now the
government is not equipped to handle
this large number of children not to
mention trying to reunite them with
their parents Alex Antonio and his
two-year-old son Jeremy were released
after being initially detained for the
maximum period of 72 hours the release
came around the same time President
Trump signed his executive order the
Honduran man told us that while in
custody he heard that families were
being separated and he feared it would
happen to him in Jeremy for the more
than 2300 children already separated
from their parents the president's
executive order may not change anything
immediately there is currently no system
in place to reunite children with
parents who Rondon - in detention
Bob Kerry is an open society fellow he
used to run the office of refugee
resettlement under the Obama
administration that is the federal
agency responsible for caring for
separated children Kerry says Orr
shelter system was designed for minors
who arrived at the border alone
typically adolescent boys and is not
really equipped for the influx of
infants toddlers and young children that
were separated from their parents
under the president's
tolerance policy this is child abuse
being perpetrated by a government early
yesterday morning these girls arrived at
a facility in New York City which Mayor
Bill de Blasio says is housing 239
separated children
the mayor says some of them arrived with
contagious conditions like chickenpox
and lice the youngest to come here they
told us was nine months old
the US government tells CBS News it
keeps track of children with a unique
identifier called an alien number name
age gender and country of origin are
also recorded awfully odd a Los Santos
an official at Catholic Charities in
Brownsville Texas says the shelter she's
visited are well-run but it's not about
how nice a facility is it's the fact
that they're not with their parents when
they go to their beds at night what do
you think they think about well failure
told us that from what she's seen every
time a child gets to a facility like
this they get medical and mental health
screenings if you will and then the
government works to figure out who
already lives in the u.s. that's related
to them government officials have
insisted to us we try and find people
here in the US who can take them but nor
that process can sometimes take up to
two months oh my gosh David you really
put it in perspective there especially
as Ophelia mentioned - it's not about
how well the shelters are run it's this
you're just there without your parents
you need someone to care for you in an
emotional way and what I keep thinking -
when you're a real little kid you don't
even know your parents name because you
know them as mommy and daddy or mommy
and poppy in this particular case so
even if you ask the child what is your
parents name they may not even be able
to tell you what the name of their
parents are is